elle s'appelle noël poignant et elle
dirige ce magasin depuis 60 ans
j'ai toujours été très attiré d'abord
par l'abbaye par le site la preuve c'est
que je vais avoir 80 ans je suis
toujours là je n'arrive pas à prendre ma
retraite comme tous les jours elle se
tient à sa place préférée dehors sur le
pas de sa porte si vous voulez entrer
attention à la marche c'est un très bon
au classement parce que je suis à la
fois la dernière est la première en
descendant
avec presque 3 millions de touristes
annuels qui passe devant sa boutique son
commerce est florissant
[Musique]
poster dans ma cuisine
ya pas de place de perdue vous avez vu
même sur la porte yade elle a des objets
les maisons habitables sur le mont saint
michel sont rares tout se ressemble tout
en hauteur plutôt petit étroites tout
collées les unes aux autres tout
mitoyenne noël ne vit pas dans cette
maison de 50 m²
c'est son petit fils qui habite la pièce
principale et aujourd'hui n'est pas une
journée comme les autres gabriel et dont
le journal local
maman chérie je suis très fier d'être
couvrir ça dans un journal je suis très
fière de toi comme toujours
en grand
si gabriel a eu droit à un article c'est
parce qu'il est un véritable passionné
d'histoire
depuis trois mois cet étudiant en
tourisme et patrimoine répertorie tous
les objets qui ont appartenu aux
habitants du rocher il les listes et
raconte leur histoire
je suis arrivé
de 249 en branle
pour trouver ces 249 objet il a commencé
par ouvrir les albums photos de sa grand
mère
donc c'est ton arrière grand père ça
c'est un arrière grand mère c'était pour
le théâtre alors en fait c'est
mademoiselle provost qui faisait la mise
en scène de petites pièces de théâtre
pour les montois pour les occuper
l'hiver noël est incollable sur le monde
elle l'a découvert à 20 ans à l'époque
elle vit près de cherbourg
le nom mont-saint-michel en 1960 tu es
venu en vacances chez mon oncle françois
ai dit tu veux faire de la voile à des
jeux de présenter un montois qui est un
bateau et tu pourras faire de la voile a
vécu voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai
connus pour son canton grand pont
six mois plus tard noël épouse claude
son petit copain de voile l'homme et
commerçants et permet à noël d'acheter
sa propre petite boutique
à l'époque les biens appartiennent à
l'évêché et ne sont pas bon marché
c'est la photo de mariage civil on en
sort de la mairie depuis six générations
la famille du mari de noël est installé
sur le mont gabriel son unique petit
fils est fier de ses racines
fait cent cinquante ans qu'on est sur le
sol allemand saint-michel ça peut
paraître beaucoup mais plusieurs
anciennes familles depuis plus de 500
ans qui sont qui sont ici topolanek je
suis footballeur quand la passerelle en
bois était recouverte et les en partie
les touristes comme ça et quand la
passerelle en bois n'était pas
recouvertes ils mettaient leur
cuissardes et c'était les hommes sur les
épaules elle est femme dans les bras
c'est marrant comme comme anecdote
aujourd'hui sur le mont à par les
touristes en fait voilà peu de choses
ont changé
la chance qu'on a d'avoir cette terrasse
il est impossible de pousser les murs
des maisons qui reste petit mais sur
cette terrasse grand-mère et petit-fils
saisissent la chance d'être seul pour
admirer une vue unique au monde au calme